as the jurors in the kyle rittenhouse
trial remain in a stalemate reportedly
not over the evidence so much as over
fear for their lives msnbc dispatched a
producer to follow the juror's bus
presumably to uncover more about their
identities
the judge
in that case did not as you might expect
take too kindly to the legacy media's
efforts to harass the jurors
police when they stopped him because he
was following in a distance of about
a block and went through a red light
pulled him over and inquired of him what
was going on and he
gave that information
and stated that he had been instructed
by ms bion
in new york to
follow the jury bus
the matter is
under further investigation at this
point
and the media has asked questions about
it that's the latest i have
um
and he was ticketed for uh
violating a traffic control signal
he's not here today from what i'm told
and
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
love that
absolutely right how can anyone expect a
fair and impartial verdict in this case
with that kind of intimidation not just
from the activists outside but the
activists who pretend to be journalists
no matter how weak the prosecution's
arguments no matter how strong the
defense's case no matter how clear the
evidence the jurors fear for their lives
and with good reason i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve mickel
who says everyone takes a beating
sometimes is known as the goodfellas
statute very well-known law this is true
and the prosecution which made that
argument that everybody takes a beating
sometimes
uh is acting like a bunch of gangsters
and
you know we all see it we all see that
the evidence is on kyle rittenhouse's
side we all see that all the pressure
and intimidation is on the side of the
prosecution but the fact is the jurors
are people all right and they're gonna
they're people who have to go about and
live their lives and their people with
families and they might succumb to that
kind of intimidation
it's really important to make sure that
you take care of your affairs with all
this crazy
political nonsense going around the
economy going up and down and up and
down you probably want some tangible
assets which is why i would recommend
you check out acre gold acre lets you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
thirty dollars a month i know what
you're thinking you're thinking michael
gold bars cost more than thirty dollars
hear me out acre has an ingenious way to
allow you to invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
you pay each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house they've also got a new 100 a
month subscription to a 5 gram gold bar
if you want to up the ante i've really
enjoyed investing in physical precious
metals i've really enjoyed investing in
acre gold go check them out today
that's get acre gold dot com slash knoll
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get
underscore acre that url is get acre
gold dot com slash knowles canada w l e
s and thank you acre gold for supporting
the show
nbc
news which is now you know which
obviously owns msnbc
nbc news sent out a very curious
non-denial denial about the incident
with the jurors bust take a listen to
this
this apparent denial which i think is
anything but quote last night a
freelancer received a traffic citation
while the traffic violation took place
near the jury van the freelancer never
contacted or intended to contact the
jurors during deliberations and never
photographed or intended to photograph
them nbc news said in a statement we
regret the incident and will fully
cooperate with the authorities on any
investigation okay hold on
hold on a second here
if you did nothing wrong
then why do you regret the incident
we did nothing wrong but we regret the
incident why because you're admitting
that you did do something wrong
it was a freelancer who received a
traffic citation why are you trying to
put distance between yourself and your
employee who you're saying look he was
working as a freelancer he write a
freelancer who's apparently working at
your direction
no no it's a freelancer it's not us okay
it was he just received a traffic
citation okay what was the traffic
citation for
why was he being pulled over in the
first place
the freelancer never contacted or
intended to contact the jurors during
deliberations
there you go there are the two words
that show you that these guys are guilty
as can be
during deliberations
no one ever said he was going to contact
them during till during deliberations
is is back when they're at the
courthouse obviously if he's chasing
their bus he's not going to be
contacting them during deliberations the
problem is he's contacting them outside
of the deliberations
and you know it and you lying hacks you
dishonest
nbc news journalists
you're admitting it here those two words
are the proof
yeah we we sent one of our
operatives to go harass the jurors to
find out more about their identities
probably to dox them at the very least
to pressure them
to
throw this kid in the can even though
all the evidence is on his side that's
what went on and nbc news tacitly at
least
admitted it
meanwhile the prosecution
is now admitting that they sent the
defense
weaker evidence than they had you
remember this issue of the videotape
there was drone footage of the inter
interaction between kyle rittenhouse and
the antifa thugs who were trying to kill
him
and
there was a difference in the quality of
the video the prosecution had extremely
high quality hd video
at least three times more clear than the
defense had which was this grainy kind
of video looked like it was filmed on a
nokia flip phone
so initially
the prosecution said no no it's not our
fault it's the defense's fault it's
their iphone or their android or their
computer they're the ones who's whose
technology messed up the video
then the defense came back and said
that's bs it's got a different file name
than the file you had so obviously it
happened when you sent the file has
nothing to do with our computers has
everything to do with what you guys did
so now
the prosecution is making the opposite
argument they're saying oh no it's
actually the guy who sent it to us
that's that's why the footage was
different for the prosecution and for
the defense
what happened
when
when detective
howard obtained the video
he airdropped it to my phone
which is a lossless type procedure at
least it didn't change anything
at some point i emailed it to myself
which did not change anything it has the
file name the long file name
i did ask detective howard to email it
to me as well
then it had the img file name
that
attorney wisco received
so somehow in this
detective howard transmitting it to
everyone if it was emailed it was
compressed
if he airdropped it it was complete
and that was not known by anyone until
a few days ago on friday
so let me get this
straight your first story is that it was
the fault of the defense computers and
then when that was shown to be bs you
blame it on the only other person that
you could blame it on other than taking
responsibility yourself and what you're
saying happened is
that
the the video man
airdropped it to you so you had the
perfect quality video
then you
emailed it to yourself
and then you separately had him email it
to the defense
and whoopsy daisy the videos that got
emailed
were of lower quality than the one that
was airdropped so one
why did you email it to yourself
if you were not going to forward it to
the to the defense
if you were just go and you already had
the video file
airdropped the high quality video file
why did you then separately have mr
video man send it to the defense
why why were you
making sure and and if you were just if
you emailed it to yourself to forward it
to the defense then why didn't you just
send them the airdrop
there seemed to be one or two extra
steps in here
that mean that this does not pass the
smell test
i never want to attribute to malice that
which is equally explained by or
explained just as well by stupidity
and the prosecution has exhibited a lot
of stupidity here
but i think they're i think they're also
exhibiting some malice i think they're
also exhibiting some corruption
i think
they're changing their story a little
bit too much
i think they're making legal arguments
that are so bogus that if they're being
made in earnest you should probably be
disbarred
the prosecutors should
or they're being made disingenuously
i don't buy it does not pass the smell
test for one
single
second
it's wrong it's wrong what they're doing
so why don't we have a verdict yet
why don't we don't have a verdict i
think because the jurors rightly are
afraid for their lives
there are reports coming out again who
knows if they're true that it's a
deadlocked jury
and so i suspect it's not because the
evidence is so clear kyle was completely
acting in self-defense the whole
narrative that we were told by the media
by the state turned out not to be true
the prosecution's case was undermined by
the prosecution's own witnesses
like the guy grosskroots who said yeah i
actually kyle only shot at me after i
was coming at him with the gun
devastating to the prosecution's case
but
the fact is that the the jury
ought to fear for their lives
the whole this whole trial started in
the first place
because
leftist activists burned down kenosha
the last time they didn't get
a
movement of the criminal justice system
that they that they wanted right
remember the cop shot that degenerate
jacob blake
rightly so absolutely rightly so he
probably should have shot him sooner
and the left didn't like that so they
burned the city down and then kyle
rittenhouse showed up and then he killed
these antifa guys who were trying to
kill him and now we're on trial now it's
going to be a vicious cycle
i don't think that this trial i said
there are two trials going on the trial
and the court of law and the trial on
the court of public opinion well i don't
think that the verdict is necessarily
going to come down to right or wrong i
think it's going to come down to
self-preservation
for a lot of these jurors
when of course it should come down to
right it just a further weakening of our
trust in the criminal justice system
you know it's very right
to protect yourself and your identity
which is why you got to check out
lifelock cyber criminals use spear
phishing attacks that are more tailored
and researched than normal scam phishing
emails
these targeted attacks focus on an
individual and try to trick them into
revealing personal information by posing
as a trusted friend
boss company or family member it is
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives every day we put our information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could harm what's yours
your finances and your credit good thing
here's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats for
instance your social security number for
sale on the dark web if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
now no one can prevent all identity
theft
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 percent off your first
year by going to lifelock.com
knowles k w l e s that's
lifelock.com for 25 off
speaking of right and wrong
governor ron desantis
gave a speech yesterday
press conference to reporters
when he was asked about his
prohibitions on vaccine mandates in
florida his protection of people's
rights and freedoms in florida
he gave one of the most perceptive
answers
on conservatism on our political rights
on what freedom really is one of the
most perceptive answers i have ever
heard from a politician take a listen
there has never been
a federal
vaccine mandate imposed on the general
public i hear people talk about you know
they used to do things in the military
yeah when i was in the military they
used to give me all kind of stuff
honestly i wish i would have thought a
little bit but i mean whatever it was
but that's much different than
regulating the military and then
imposing it on civilians in society it's
never been done before it's not they
don't have the power to do it there's no
federal police power states have the pe
the federal the the police power so
that's from a constitutional perspective
it is worlds worlds apart now some
people say hey these local governments
wanted to lock down businesses they
wanted to force mandates they wanted to
keep the kids locked out of school yeah
you're damn right i overruled them on
that because they were wrong
and the fact of the matter is
the fact of the matter is
you you don't have right to you don't
have the right to do wrong
the fact of the matter is you don't have
the right to do
wrong
that is one of the most
perceptive
insightful observations about american
government and the nature of liberty
itself that i have ever heard from a
politician
you don't have the right to do wrong
the typical republican answer that you
would have heard for the past 20 years
as well look
you look people have the right to do
whatever they want if people want to do
something crazy with their bodies if
people want to do something crazy and
it's and it
doesn't violate the certain limits of
some constitutional interpretation then
that's that's totally their right i
don't agree with it but it's their right
you have the the squishy republican
answer would be you do have the right to
do wrong
the
correct answer is you do not have the
right to do wrong
this is why some of the squishy
republicans will say look we're not
going to have government mandates for
the vaccine but if a private business
wants to that's totally cool
private business can do whatever they
have the right to do whatever they want
even a bunch of wrong stuff
no they don't no they don't you don't
have the right to do wrong this is
something about ron desantis that is
powerful
he talks like a linebacker and kind of
looks like a linebacker right he's just
this big guy who's like look okay when i
was in the military right he reminds you
i was in the military when i was in the
military they shot me with all kinds of
stuff it's pretty stupid i actually kind
of wish i hadn't done that but anyway i
did that right and he just talks in this
very
blunt
down-to-earth way
but then he'll say something that is
philosophically extraordinarily
sophisticated
you do not have the right to do wrong
so
he
because he has that philosophical
premise he's gotten everything right
about kovid in florida
right and it so those just seem like
very pragmatic practical no we're not
going to force masks we're not going to
force vaccine we're not going to let
businesses force these sorts of things
but it's because he's got real
philosophical clarity here and i think
this is the reason that he's doing very
well in the pre-potential running for
president type of thing is because ron
desantis is where the the new right is
which is much less libertarian and it's
much more conservative
this is why he's doing well now if
donald trump runs for president again
it's probably all a moot point because
there won't be a primary because he'll
he'll clear the field
but very impressive stuff
from desantis you you want not just do
you want that philosophical clarity but
you want to be able to balance out
the
talking like a truck driver but having
the the political vision to to know
where the country's supposed to go the
the lower and the higher right the the
kind of on the ground tangible based in
reality and also the pie in the sky
abstract philosophy and you saw a little
bit more of the former when you looked
at where he was giving this speech from
he was giving this press conference from
brandon florida
it's
obvious the people in the crowd that
they believe you chose brandon because
of the thing that goes around on certain
websites is this why you came to brandon
because of the trolling of the body
administration so i think that brandon
florida is a great american city i think
the people here are fantastic
and i can tell you
[Applause]
my only negative on brandon was they
when i was growing up playing baseball
they always used to beat us every year
uh but now i think uh you know as
governor i'm really proud to be able to
do it i want to thank brandon honda for
hosting us here today
and we're proud to be able to make a
stand for freedom in brandon florida
so the guy knows how to troll
i don't think he chose brandon florida
because it's his favorite honda
dealership okay i don't i think it might
have something to do with the chant
about joe biden
that's good you're going to need both of
those things now now
it's very early
it's 2021.
the presidential is not until 2024.
in 2013
for instance
no one could have guessed that trump was
going to be the nominee
people thought oh it's going to be bobby
jindal oh it's going to be this guy it's
going to be that guy and it just wasn't
so i
ron desantis has a long way to go to
prove himself there are going to be
other candidates that come up donald
trump might run and wipe them all out
there might be a nominee
who we've never heard of but the reason
i mention this desantis clip
is because he is seeing something here
okay and i think
you don't have the right to do wrong
that is where the republican party
is right now and it's it's
heading in that direction the stragglers
who are not there yet are heading in
that direction and i think
whoever is going to be the nominee
whether it's donald trump himself
i think they're going to have to be in
that area they're going to have to be
doing that thing and desantis is doing
an impressive job of that right now
speaking of the brandon administration
you know there's a little infighting
going on
between kamala harris
and
joe biden
joe biden obviously doesn't like kamala
harris
kamala harris launched a presidential
campaign calling him a racist
kamala harris doesn't like joe biden
joe biden keeps throwing her under the
bus and saying oh yeah i'm putting
kamala in charge of illegal immigration
yeah deal with the border kamala
good luck
okay enjoy see you
enjoy texas
uh and he's not backing her up and he's
saying nice things about his other
minions he's saying nice things about p
buddha judge for instance but he's not
really defending kamala harris and now
kamala harris's flax are going to the
press and saying yeah we think joe
biden's a racist so there's all this
infighting going on jen saki goes out to
try to throw some water on this she's
asked do you think the criticism of
kamala harris is because of racism
you took to twitter this week to defend
the most prominent woman there the vice
president after there were stories about
her this weekend that mentioned low
approval ratings allegations of staff
problems
some of her allies have attributed this
to sexism do you think she is receiving
more criticism because she's the first
woman and first woman of color to serve
as vice president
yes
criticism from the outside absolutely i
do think that it is uh been uh easier
uh and harsher uh from some in the right
wing who have gone after her because she
is the first woman the first woman of
color
criticism from the outside
what about the other criticism darling
because camalleris doesn't really need
to worry about criticism from the
outside from the republicans right now
it's from you guys it's from donald
trump it's not from donald trump it's
from joe biden sorry i got confused over
who the president was it's from joe
biden it's why was kamala harris the
first person out of the democrat primary
is it because of racism and sexism no no
it's only republicans who are racist and
sexist
democrats hate kamala harris for
completely different reasons that's why
it's just the go-to oh yeah yeah yeah oh
totally yeah racism sexism
it reminds me of this one time david
webb
you know was on on the radio and uh
someone woman called in black woman
called in and said david webb you're
just exposing your white privilege she
didn't realize david webb's a black guy
it was on radio so she could she
couldn't say oh yeah it's always racism
and sexism well okay honey what what's
your excuse
why does joe biden seem to be going
after kamala harris why do the democrats
not like kamalaires you're going to need
an answer on that before 2024 or 2020.
you're going to need an answer on that
when you try to figure out who your next
presidential candidates going to be
frankly i'm not sure whoever the
candidate is is going to be able to do
well if gas prices keep going up which
is why
you got to check out get upside i am
thrilled to introduce an incredible app
that everyone who buys gas needs to know
about that is get upside
right now our listeners are making up to
25 cents for every single gallon of gas
every single time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles canon wles and get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free and use
promo code knowles canon wles to get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks per month in cash back
there's no cash there's only cash goes
straight to your bank account or paypal
or if you prefer an e-gift card for
amazon or other brands download the free
get upside app use promo code knowles
and get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
speaking of racism
senator john kennedy
one of the most entertaining members of
the united states senate he is if you're
not familiar with john kennedy he's the
very folksy sounding conservative
republican who you know he'll he'll be
grilling a can and he'll say now well
listen here you know i or he'll go on
he'll often go on cable news and he'll
say listen i remember the last time a
possum skinned my granddaddy he told me
you know he's got all these really
folksy expressions but beneath the
folksy expressions he's always making
these very perceptive points he's
very very intelligent he knows he's very
strategic and kind of like we were
talking about desantis making these deep
philosophical points in a very
down-to-earth way john kennedy does a
similar kind of thing
so john kennedy was just grilling saul
omarova
saul omarova is joe biden's nominee for
comptroller of the currency so the
person that we're going to put in charge
of the currency and the problem with
saul
umarova is that she
is a communist that's not i'm not
exaggerating i'm not being hyperbolic
she's an actual
communist and so senator kennedy
asked her about this
you used to be a member of a group
called
the young communist
didn't you
senator uh are you referring to
my membership in the youth communist
organization while i was growing up in
the soviet union i don't know i was i
just i wanted to ask you that question
well senator i there was a group called
the young communists and you were a
member is that right
i'm not exactly sure which group you're
referring to well the formal name of it
is
the leninist communist young union of
the russian federation
and it's also known as the leninist
comsomal of the russian federation
and it's commonly referred to as the
young communists
were you a member
senator
i was born and grew up in the soviet
union okay now before we get to her
bogus excuses just look that take a
master class lesson here in rhetoric and
politics from john kennedy he's sitting
there he's got no paper that he's
holding up right he's just looking
and he's playing dumb he goes ah now i
heard you were a member of the young
communists is that right and so everyone
who has their prejudices against
conservatives against southerners
they're going to look at that say oh
here we go red scare again joe mccarthy
look at this bloviating guy doesn't
there's no idea what he's talking about
there's no group called the young
communists and she thinks she's she's
just all of the young
the young communists yeah i heard you're
part of the young communist in that
right
um senator i don't i don't know
what on earth you're talking about so
okay well here let me check the actual
name is the leninist commune and then he
goes on because he's got all the details
right so he leads her into this trap
to sort of deny the young communist
connection he goes well here's the
official name and here's what it's known
as and here's how long you were a member
of it and here is oh oh that oh yeah
that group so now she's got a pivot
now she pivots to well i was i grew up
in the soviet union i was so oppressed
there i we were all you can't bla if a
kid grew up in nazi germany he was part
of hitler youth you actually can't you
can't blame them all the kids were part
of that so you just just like that you
can't blame this woman for being part of
the young communists right right well
kennedy keeps grilling her
you wrote your thesis in college at
moscow state university on the title was
karl marx's economic analysis
and the theory of revolution in the
capital
but you won't send senator to me a copy
you studied at university at moscow
state university scientific communism
which is the science regarding the
working class struggle and the socialist
agenda in 2019
not 30 years ago
in a canadian documentary you called
the financial services industry quote
a quintessential ass
industry
you wrote a paper called systemically
significant prices calling for the
federal government
to set wages food gas prices
in 2020 you wrote a paper called the
people's ledger
where you said we need to abolish bank
accounts and make everybody set up an
account at the fed would the federal
government have access to your data he
goes on he's got this woman dead to
rights
and he lets her he first lets her make
the condescending response right um you
don't know what you're talking about
senator then he allows her to play the
victim i was just i grew up in the
soviet union i had no and then he says
well no but you weren't just in the
group when you were eight or nine years
old you went on to study scientific
communism and you wrote your thesis in a
defense of karl marx's economics and
then
actually just over the last couple of
years you've been
defending communist policies including a
takeover of private property by the
government
take over of private bank accounts
just within the problem isn't that you
were a communist when you were a kid the
problem is that you are a communist now
and she oh
boy
does she look
bad now can
the republicans actually railroad this
nominee i'm skeptical of that
but the reason i bring it up one is to
show you the radicalism of the biden
administration two is to to
show you this great political tool all
of us could take a lesson on this
manage expectations
john kennedy this very very
sophisticated man
walks up and he just he just talked like
a good old boy you know just like a good
old uncle bill you know and he uh down
here now listen here you and he
makes everyone underestimate him and
then
he clobbers them speaking of subverting
expectations i have to this is going to
be a little bit of a weird story but i
have to get to it
laura ingram's show the other night
raymond arroyo is on
and they do
they have a discussion
where there seems to be some confusion
between the host and the guest
and the liberal media went crazy over
this
you know i was watching an episode of uh
you where measles came up
wait wait wait when did i mention
measles
i don't know it was on you
wait
[Music]
what was on me what are you talking
about right what is
we never did a measles and vaccine
episode is this a joke i don't even know
what you're talking about it was on you
it was on youtube i've never had raymond
i've never had measles what are you
talking about this is stupid it was an
episode of a show laura
what's it called
you
you it's called you i've never done a
show on measles i i just completely give
up we gotta get it it's a show i give up
called you on netflix
there's a show called lowering on
netflix
i'm moving on to adele i can't explain
this to you the pop singer all right so
this is obviously a bit they're doing
who's on first okay and whether i think
it's kind of funny but if you if you
maybe you think it's funny maybe you
don't think it's funny
they're obviously just doing who's on
first i don't know what's on first no
what's on second i don't know third base
right they're just doing that but about
this this netflix show and the left
didn't get it
and the left said oh these idiots these
it's so obviously a bit
but they didn't look at these oh my gosh
i can't believe this craziness that
the takeaway from it
is not whether or not you know this is
the funniest bit in the world the
takeaway is the left
does not understand the right at all
they don't get it they think we're so
dumb and evil and they just like so
don't
get what we're saying and what we
believe and you and you're seeing this
play out right now in the
trial of kyle written asked you're
seeing a play out everywhere where the
the facts are sort of secondary to the
left just imposing their will without
even considering what the right has to
say
you know as the first people to file
a lawsuit against the biden
administration for their
unconstitutional vaccine mandates we at
the daily wire are pleased to see that
the biden administration suspended their
implementation and enforcement this week
but the fight is just getting started we
still have to win the court case so sign
our petition against joe biden's vaccine
mandate over at dailywire.com
do not comply to send a message to the
biden administration we've had over 600
000 people sign the petition but we're
aiming to get to 1 million signatures
head on over to dailywire.com do not
comply to sign the petition today also
if you haven't signed up to mount
walsh's newsletter then i highly suggest
you do not only will you be getting a
piece of matt's mind delivered to your
inbox every friday but you'll be
automatically entered into the running
for his beloved banjo hurry up because
if you don't sign up by tomorrow
saturday the 20th the incredibly lucky
winner who gets matt's banjo will not be
you head on over to dailywire.com banjo
to subscribe to matt's newsletter we'll
be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag first
question up from daniel hi michael i've
been struggling with a porn addiction
for quite some time now and lately i've
been noticing the toll it has taken not
just on my moods but on my ability to
retain working memory my ability to
concentrate and my ability to stay
active and it just so happens that the
daily wire recently published a list of
reasons to quit porn and among them are
these very side effects my question is
this of what you've read and spoken to
people about
to what extent can this damage be
reversed if i succeed in my efforts to
get rid of this addiction for good for
good through prayer accountability
personal discipline etc will i still be
left with permanent damage thanks love
the show
well
i
actually have two friends
who have dealt with this i'm not saying
two friends who have looked at naked
ladies on the internet i'm seeing two
friends who really
had a very serious addiction to this
sort of thing and it really had all the
side effects that you're talking about
and it took them a long time it was like
it was like
other friends of mine who have dealt
with drug addictions or alcohol
addiction i mean it was certainly to
that extent and
uh as f as far as i know as far as i can
tell they both did come out of it the
brain is a pretty elastic thing
and one of the real temptations of the
devil one of the real
um
snares here
is to convince you that you can never
get any better and so why even try
you're never going to kick the bottle
just have another drink you might as
well you're never gonna kick it
oh come on you can't you're not gonna
quit dope you gotta just shoot it up you
gotta you never you're it's you're not
it's not possible for you and it's the
same thing with something like porn or
any other addiction
um it's a very pervasive addiction too i
mean this is something that actually
should make you feel a little bit better
about it is that uh what the the average
age of of male exposure to porn is like
11 years old now or something so
this is something that especially for
younger people i hear from zoomers all
the time you're
very possibly a zoomer yourself
you know there they will have seen these
things when they're very very young
it's obviously not a conscious choice
they made but then they get ensnared in
it uh yeah
the thing also that i think one learns
about with any kind of addiction
is that
there's no there's no shortcut in this
life there's no way around
virtue
if you if you want to be free
you need to
pursue virtue and flee vice
you you just have to there's no way
around it and we're very confused about
that today because we think that we can
be free
and then do whatever drugs we want look
at whatever porn we want sleep with
whoever we want eat whatever just do you
know follow our appetites but we can't
the very act of doing those things
as you do them you are losing your
freedom and then you become enslaved to
these to these things and you can't
resist your your appetite
totally dominates your rational will and
you lose your freedom
but
uh it's it's a pervasive problem a lot
of people have come
out of it and you can and the way to do
it is accountability prayer and just
focusing on one one thing that you know
i'll give you the catholic perspective
on
i'm not just this particular sin but on
all sin
one thing that
will really persuade you not to sin or
not to sin as much or to think twice
about it
is confession you know there's the
sacrament of confession in the catholic
church where you have to go into a box
and you confess your sins out loud to a
priest
and it's
very difficult to do i've done it a
zillion times and it's still difficult
for me to do no matter what the sin is
it can seem like the most mild moderate
but you're going there and saying i did
this wrong thing and i will tell you if
you get into the habit of of doing this
of confession
then the minute you want to
do whatever you're in this case you know
look at porn or something
you're going to think twice about it
because you just think i just don't want
to
have to go to confession i just don't
have to tell the priest this and make
the time
so
i i wish you luck
i think your prospects are looking very
good the brain is very elastic my
friends who have dealt with this
particular problem
seem
entirely better now you know much much
much better and and
as you may know people have dealt with
other addictions and other problems and
how many people do we know who
were alcoholics and now they've
recovered
you say well can the brain ever recover
the brain recovers just fine you can do
it you can do it buddy from elise hey
michael i'm a 16 year old girl i'm
conservative and share the belief that
generally women should be mothers
however i've personally never wanted
children and feel that god has called me
on an entirely different path
how would you approach this as a
believer
oh well i
i would probably discern a vocation
right if i felt that i'm not being
called to marriage and god is calling me
to a path of celibacy then i would
probably pursue i would discern of
whether or not i had a vocation meaning
am i supposed to be a priest or in your
case are you supposed to be a nun for
example
and not everyone is
i did not have a vocation
and
i was kind of an atheist at the time
when i guess i would have been
discerning these things but i didn't
manifestly i did not some people do it's
a gift given to some people you know
it's a charism and so
if you are that then i you know i don't
know again i don't know your specific
religious leanings but i would discern
that you might be uh you might be called
to be a nun
and uh that's great there's some pretty
pretty cool nuns out there today i mean
some of the greatest women in the
history of the world have been nuns have
been called to a religious life
and even now you know i i am going to
see in an event soon enough a sister
deirdre
byrne who's a really impressive nun she
spoke at the rnc
she's you know she's in the military and
she's a surgeon and she's a non very
very impressive people
so
you know best of luck with discerning
that
certainly we can all pray for you from
nicholas
hey michael my fellow swarthy former
westchester new york resident how would
you respond to the argument that a woman
taking a man's last name after marriage
is an outdated and sexist tradition is
there any reason behind doing so other
than its tradition my fiance has heard
from many of her engaged friends that
they either plan on having the man take
the woman's last name
that's good
that's
poor schmucks or to create a new hybrid
name based on a combination of the two
last names
luckily i will be marrying a smart
beautiful catholic italian woman who
plans on taking my last name when we get
married in june could use some ammo for
arguments with all these new york libs
you the man thank you very much okay
you will
inevitably be taking a man's name
your family inevitably will take a man's
name whether your wife takes your name
or you take her name or you both keep
your names you will have a man's name
you will either have
your last the husband's last name or
the wife's father's last name
and let's say that the wife actually was
named after her mother okay then you're
gonna be taking the wife's mother's
father's last name but somewhere down
the line
you will be taking a man's last name
so
if you take the husband's last name this
would seem to reflect that the man has a
special leadership role in the household
headship of the household doesn't mean
he's a knuckle dragging dictator but
there is a
there is a leadership role for a man in
a household which i certainly think is
the case
if you take
the woman's last name then you're saying
that the father-in-law has a special
leadership role in the household okay
not the way i want to run my household
but that's fine
and if
the woman does not take the man's last
name or you you know then then you're
saying we're not
really one flesh right we're still two
separate individuals who've consented to
do certain things together you know we
share a dishwasher
and if you come up with a hybrid name
together if you just make up a name
then what you're saying is we are doing
this thing together but we have no
connection to our past no connection to
our family
no we are our own thing totally divorced
from tradition and custom and convention
good luck with that each man has a very
small
quantity of reason and i don't think
unfettered reason
and un
unfettered atomized individualism is is
really going to lead you to a
flourishing life
the one exception i will say to this
it's a friend of mine
had a very complicated last name that
was difficult to pronounce and probably
not great for business and he did take
his wife's last name because it was
really uh succinct and easy to say and
looked kind of cool so there might be
prudential reasons to try to work your
way around it but i think generally
speaking
uh your wife should take your last name
from
thomas uh hey mr knowles
i think the metaverse is great the meta
this is mark zuckerberg's new thing
where you just plug into the matrix for
the very same reason i think it's
terrible it's just like drugs or alcohol
or porn it's an escape from reality i've
gone through a ton of trauma in my 19
years of living as a young adult who
struggles with suicidal thoughts a world
away from this one sounds amazing sadly
i know the metaverse is in fact a prison
worse than this world and not the heaven
we want it to be so i would want to go
to the metaverse to escape my giants
here
demons you might say the more
conservative i get and the more faith i
put in god the more my family hates me
and the girl i love just sees me like an
older brother i've wanted to run away
for years and the metaverse seems like a
great way to do it or like a way to do
it even though i know i would only be
running into a dark lonely cell
sincerely a hurting soul well listen pal
i'm sorry you're going through all this
it's really really tough
the first
step to overcoming a problem is knowing
that you have a problem and so you know
that you have this problem
of trauma that you've got to process
a problem of not particularly enjoying
your place in in the world and thinking
you might need to make a change in your
social life
and this problem of recognizing the
temptation of fantasy which is what the
metaverse is so that's good i think
you're really pretty far ahead of the
game here
um and you're you said your family hates
you because you believe in god well you
know that's what the bible says and they
say they will hate you for my sake so
you can take i think a great deal of
solace and comfort in that
what would i recommend doing well one i
would recommend seeing a psychologist if
you're if you're trying to deal with
psychological trauma from your past that
if you're not doing that already i would
recommend you do that i'm not saying you
take a bunch of happy pills i'm saying
you speak to someone who might have some
expertise in working through this i
recommend talking to a priest you know
you say you believe in god so i would
definitely do that
and i would resist the temptation you
know it you know that it needs to be
resisted and sometimes we just need a
little comfort to resist these things
comfort in the sense of bishop odo on
the bio tapestry wielding a club
smacking his own men and saying get back
to battle and don't retreat
that would be the thing to do because
you're you're right the
escapism you know booze
drugs porn the metaverse
even video games can become a problem
like this
what what they often are about is
escaping time we want to be outside of
time you feel under pressure you feel
like ah i just i don't like being in
this world so you just you try to get
out of that but you can't get out of
that
you'll be far more edified to work out
your problems here in the real world and
maybe that means making some changes
maybe you have to make some changes to
your social life find a new girl that
you're attracted to who cares the girl
doesn't like you so whatever there's
other fish in the sea get over you know
she doesn't sound that great to me
your family doesn't like you well maybe
you need to put a little distance
between your family or maybe you need to
work things out with your family but you
know
maybe you've got to sort those things
out maybe you do have to move maybe you
don't need to move you're 19 you're very
very young you work these things out
people get better at these sorts of
things
and and the final part of that is maybe
you need to recognize the
productivity of suffering
no one wants to suffer suffering is
terrible i'm sorry you got to deal with
it but suffering is a
can be a sanctifying thing you can react
to it in a way with patience and
humility that is edifying it will build
you up
i just read jane eyre you ever read jane
eyre terrific book
and the first part of the book is on
this very point might be worth doing
that that would be a much more
productive thing to do to read to read a
great novel like jane eyre than to go
into the metaverse stay strong you know
you know the answer
uh
i think you just need a little comfort
and so i'm happy to provide that if we
can
all right
20 seconds left i'm still going to get
to a question from jared michael
when when talking about destigmatizing
pedophiles oh my gosh it's a heavy
episode guys heavy mailbag shouldn't we
approach as some people have evil
thoughts and
shouldn't we approach and this is worded
a little weird that's never okay to act
on you should get counseling and maybe
isolate yourself encourage people to be
better than their urges in this day and
age do you think our friends on the
other side could accept this standard if
so we begin to chip away at all this
gender stuff right if we basically say
that you got to work on these urges yes
yeah that is the problem the one of the
central problems of the gender ideology
is that we're told that all of our
desires are fine and maybe you can't act
on all of them that you can act on
most of them these days but oh the
desires are fine you should never try to
change your desires or couch your
desires but the fact is we can shape our
desires maybe not totally this is a
fallen world and we have natural
inclinations that we can overcome but we
can we can order our desires
a little kid craves milk chocolate all
the time an adult craves
filet mignon this is a
cultivation of tastes and and this is
true of of all of our desires you can
aim your desire toward vice and then
you'll get more of it or you can aim it
toward virtue and you'll get more of
that as well that is the only way that
you could overcome the gender theory
stuff but it requires a lot of work on
on reshaping the moral discourse that's
our show i'm michael knowles the michael
and i'll show you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin